[Music]
from the very opening scene of the
batman new villain the riddler enacts a
murderous and effective campaign of
terror to expose the corruption at the
heart of gotham city the frightening
villain first targets city officials
while leaving a series of riddles chock
full of clues for batman to uncover the
conspiracy that has turned gotham rotten
in fact riddler later tells an appalled
batman that he was inspired by the caped
crusader's own use of violence and
crafting his plans to permanently change
the city and its infrastructure the
riddler is eventually captured but
batman is too late to work out the final
part of his plan after the riddler's car
bombs destroy the breakwaters of gotham
flooding the downtown area his followers
intend to kill mayor-elect bella royale
and shooting to the crowd of people
taking refuge in the stadium batman and
catwoman are forced to fight the
riddler's devotees and save the city
residents fans praised how the early
stages of the riddler's master plan felt
but were very split over his scheme in
the last act here's why in the
discussion of the batman and the r movie
subreddit some superhero fans were
frustrated by how nonsensical the
riddler's endgame is compared to what
one user called quote his brilliant plan
to publicly embarrass expose and
assassinate the city's leadership
earlier in the movie the riddler did
tell his devotees that he wanted real
change and acted in gotham but creating
a major disaster via bombing gotham sea
walls and then using that flood to kill
mayor-elect bella real is not on par
with the string of killings riddler
mastermind earlier in the movie the same
redditor also noticed that the mayhem
didn't even make sense they wrote the
plan was to get everyone in the stadium
and have like 10 guys in masks snipe
everyone why not just blow up the
building the scheme seems like it'd be
too easy for someone like batman to foil
compared to the destructive power of a
bomb or another device it's
understandable then that some fans took
issue with the riddler expanding his
lethal crusade to ordinary citizens
instead of just corrupt city officials
part of the issue is that unlike batman
begins which involves the villain
tampering with gotham's water supply in
the final act the destruction of
gotham's sea wall isn't foreshadowed or
telegraphed to the audience at all one
reddit user noticed that writing at no
point in the movie are we ever told
about a sea wall keeping gotham dry
suddenly the riddler is blowing up dikes
to drown the city and wash everything
away it's worth noting that there were
some passing references to the sea wall
like hidden on riddler's floor map and
in newspaper clippings so you would have
had to pay attention to the small
details to figure out the clues the
flooding also doesn't feel consistent
with the tone of the dark stripped-down
film compared to the detective story at
the heart of the batman the last 30
minutes are more of the climax to what
feels like a standard action-packed
superhero blockbuster one reddit user
wrote that in their opinion the final
act was needlessly dramatic compared to
the rest of the movie that felt pretty
grounded until that point however other
redditors pointed out that the final
scenes helped complete batman's arc
throughout the batman the titular hero
often comes off more like a movie
monster than a superhero batman is
obsessed with the gotham project and as
bella real observes isn't doing much to
help the population when he's bruce
wayne you really could be doing more for
this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything but when
batman saves the innocent folks trapped
in the flooded downtown arena this leads
mayor real and the helpless citizens to
trust him enough to lead them out of the
flood he also recognizes that the
riddler shooters are traumatized angry
people much like himself one redditer
argued that seeing batman evolve as a
hero through those scenes was crucial
additionally bruce empathizes with the
people he rescues as well as the
shooters in the end batman decides that
he can't only personify vengeance but
should also be an inspiration to the
residents of gotham who just survived a
terrifying event arguably the batman
could have had a different climax but it
might not have delivered the same
emotional payoff
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you